do you think the spread of marijuana use
is likely to make a more Americans more
conservative or more liberal what do you
think
do you think just all things being equal
you got a guy he's kind of politically
neutral and you say hey buddy come on
over here to the cigar bar and we're
going to talk about GK Chesterton in
edmonburg you get a guy who say hey
buddy come on down to the cool bar and
we're gonna throw back some beers not
Bud Lights and we're gonna hang out with
the boys and play poker okay that's
gonna push a guy into a certain culture
or you say hey buddy come on over here
and start ripping out of this bong and
then we can all be in a drum circle and
engage in witchcraft like what direction
do you want to push people in do you
does anybody seriously believe
that more potheads is going to make
America more conservative